hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
right here in front of me I have apples
2019 16 inch MacBook Pro and I have the
brand new 20/20 HP omen now this is
probably one of the weirdest laptops
I've ever compared to a macbook but it
has something very special and that is
Intel's 10th generation
chip it's the i7 and it's actually the
six core and the cool thing about this
comparison is that we believe that this
processor is going to be going into the
refreshed 16 inch macbook pro so in this
comparison we're going to compare
everything including the keyboards the
track pads that displays the size the
port's the performance and basically
everything else like that just to see if
it's worth paying over $1,000 more for
the 16 inch macbook pro or if you can
buy this for a low price of $1,300 and
get some decent performance and of
course this is focused on gaming but you
could actually do some video editing and
other work like that so with that the
first thing I want to compare is the
size now even though this is a 15-inch
laptop compared to 16 this thing's
actually bigger than the 16 inch MacBook
Pro I actually feel that it's wider and
it's definitely taller and it gets even
worse I guess you can say if you look at
the thickness this thing is massive
compared to the MacBook Pro which is
relatively slim if you look at it from
the side there's a huge difference in
thickness and due to the large size it
also weighs quite a bit more we got four
point four pounds for the MacBook Pro
and around five point four for the HP
Homan so this is definitely a big laptop
and basically if you care about
portability you're definitely gonna want
to go for the MacBook Pro 16 because
it's a lot thinner and it's easier to
carry around and lighter now the
advantage for the HP laptop is the ports
so let's compare those the MacBook Pro
simply gets four Thunderbolt three ports
nice and standard they're very very fast
ports but they're limited along with of
course a headphones
now on the HP laptop it's a whole
different story we have a headphone jack
right there we have a fundable 3 port
which is nice we have a mini DisplayPort
right there
we have 2 USB a ports we have an HDMI
port and we actually have Ethernet and
it's actually a cool way that they did
this you can actually pull this back to
plug in your Ethernet and when you're
not using it it kind of snaps in and
it's flush with the design which is nice
and of course the power plug in and on
the other side we have another USB a
port and an SD card slot so this thing
is definitely the winner in terms of
ports and it's nice to see those legacy
ports or what the macbook pro calls them
come back on here and before we crack
open these displays I want to turn them
over to the back and just compare the
exhaust vents and as you guys can see on
the HP we have a ton of vents huge
cooling system it's definitely a lot
more thick and we have actually a
exhaust vent here on the side and we
have exhaust vents here on the back now
the MacBook Pro is definitely more
subtle we have these thin strips right
here on the side for cooling and of
course another thin strip for the
exhaust vents on the back and it looks
like the speaker grilles are actually
right here on the HP omen so it kind of
bounces off your desk and shoots up so
we're gonna test those really soon now
one thing that's already annoying me a
little bit is all of the fingerprints
that I'm getting like I just started
using this there's fingerprints all over
it because it's black compared to no
fingerprints right here because just you
just don't see them on the MacBook now I
love Apple's hinges because you
literally one hand open it up like that
let's test out the omen no nope it's not
too bad actually but definitely not as
good of a hinge now one thing you'll
instantly notice is this gap near the
hinge on the HP this is definitely a
weird design choice that they made I'm
definitely not used to that but I could
see some people might think it's cool
now just looking at the layout of these
displays I like that the MacBook Pro
kinda has a full sheet of glass covering
the whole thing compared to the HP
having this kind of
old-style where the display is only on
the inside and you have like plastic
covering the whole exterior where the
bezels are at so definitely makes it
look old compared to the MacBook Pro
which I don't really like about it now
going down to the keyboards there's one
huge difference and that is the HP
choosing to add a numpad on the side so
they're using the full width compared to
the MacBook Pro which actually has some
pretty large speaker grilles on the
sides and they don't have the numpad and
of course the MacBook Pro has the touch
bar just like that so some people don't
like it I actually prefer the function
keys like you get on the HP getting into
the typing feel of the keyboard I really
like the MacBook Pros new magic keyboard
it gives you a lot more key travel than
before then the butterfly keys and some
good feedback as well now going over to
the omen I actually really like how much
key travel that you get of course is a
this is a thicker laptop so you get more
key travel and the feedback is also
really good it's a really tough choice
they feel pretty similar but yeah I
think the HP feels a little bit mushy
it's on the mushy side so I think I'd
actually go with the MacBook Pro for the
keyboard feel now if we move down to the
track pads this is where we see probably
the biggest difference ever so apples
track pads are known to be the best
because they use their force touch
technology so it doesn't actually click
it has a motor that vibrates and
assimilates a click so you can customize
all the different pressure settings and
the cool thing is that it doesn't use a
diving board design so anywhere you
click you get an even clicking feel
feels really great so best trackpad I've
ever used and it's also very large over
to the omen you get this tiny offset
trackpad it's not centered and the weird
thing is I doesn't actually click you
can just do tap to click and right below
it you actually have two buttons you
have a left click button and a right
click button and that's totally weird
like I don't know I don't remember the
last time I had a trackpad that was like
this that's like years and years ago and
we had these track pads
so is it it's a little bit weird to use
definitely not used to it so the MacBook
Pro is definitely the winner in terms of
the trackpad now let's move on and
compare the displays between these two
so the MacBook Pro has a 16 inch display
compared to 15.6 inch now I'm noticing
something really really weird the
display on the HP omen looks very blue
kind of like almost with like a greenish
tint and I'm on Google which is a white
page this looks just horrible
the MacBook definitely looks a lot more
white but it is using true tone so it's
automatically changing the white balance
to make it look more white now I'm gonna
turn that off and even with that off the
HP still looks so weird and off now
another difference is that this uses a
anti-glare display so it's kind of like
a matte display and because of that
everything doesn't look that sharp like
I'm looking at the Google image the the
logo right there it does not look sharp
at all the colors look bad compared to a
regular display on the MacBook
everything looks great and you're
actually getting around 2.8 K resolution
compared to 1920 by 1080 on the HP omen
but of course there's a difference in
refresh rate we have a hundred and
forty-four Hertz right here compared to
only 60 on the MacBook now of course the
MacBook Pro is meant for life
productivity and stuff like that and
this is a gaming machine so 144 Hertz is
definitely what you want but the display
quality is just so bad it's not sharp
not color accurate but if you're gaming
it might not matter and as far as the
brightness the MacBook Pro is definitely
much more bright compared to the HP now
I have a video playing right here and
you can easily tell how much better the
colors the contrast everything is the
detail on the MacBook Pro compared to
the HP which really does not look that
great the colors just don't look nearly
as vibrant and everything has like a
blue tint to it because of the display
now let's go ahead and get into this
speaker comparison between these two
obviously the MacBook Pro costs over a
thousand dollars more so we should
expect the speakers to be better but I
notice on the
HP that there's Bang & Olufsen speakers
so let's see how they sound so let me
know what you guys thought down in the
comment section below but that was a
massive difference
the MacBook Pro is better in literally
every single way the maids the wide
range of frequencies especially the bass
the volume now the speakers didn't sound
that bad on the omen except it was
lacking some bass and definitely
definitely lacking volume so the MacBook
Pro easily bit out the HP however the HP
omen should actually perform a lot
better than the 16 inch MacBook Pro so
let's get into the performance
comparison starting with Geekbench v now
these both have i7s their six cores but
the one in the omen has the brand-new
tenth generation one which we do expect
to be put into the sixteen inch macbook
pro hopefully sometime the summer so I
got the scores back and the performance
is a little bit underwhelming on the HP
4900 multi-core score compared to 5500
now the reason is because neither of
them are plugged in however I did check
the power settings and it's set to Best
Performance as you guys can see so you
have to be plugged in to get the full
performance so let's go ahead and plug
that in and retest this alright now that
is what I'm talking about check out that
single core score 1249 on the HP that's
actually higher than any Mac ever the
multi-core score is insane 6400 compared
to 5600 now that is almost as powerful
as the eight core processor on the
current 16 inch macbook pro so if we're
getting this chip in a 16 inch refresh
that is great news
now the even cooler part about the HP is
that it comes with a GTX 2060 dedicated
graphics card compared to an AMD 5300 M
so let's go ahead and test Geekbench
fives grab
test metal on the MacBook and CUDA on
the HP alright this is insane
23,000 on the MacBook Pro 77,000 on the
HP almond that is over three times the
graphics score so basically this tells
us that anything to do with graphics
rendering video editing and especially
gaming is gonna be a lot better on the
HP so let's go ahead and test gaming
performance using the Unigine Heaven
benchmark so while this is running I can
easily tell that the HP is getting a lot
more FPS but I am noticing a lot more
fan noise from that 2060 graphics card
alright so we got our scores 45 FPS on
the MacBook Pro and 95 on the HP omen so
basically over double the score so this
is gonna be great for gaming and that's
also why they have the 144 Hertz display
so if you guys are interested in
watching us play some games on this
machine go ahead and subscribe right now
so let's finish our performance testing
off with Cinebench R 20 so we just got
our scores and this is probably the most
interesting part of this video even
though we got a much higher geekman
score it's actually almost the same just
slightly better than the MacBook Pro
which is very surprising now I think
what's happening is that Windows is
limiting the power on the chip
whereas Mac OS on the MacBook Pro is
just pushing this chip to its limits so
that's why we're getting such good
performance even though this is not the
tenth gentian like the HP omen
so now let's finish off with our
conclusion obviously the HP is a much
better deal for what you get because
it's only $1300 compared to 2400 on the
MacBook Pro and you're getting a GTX
2060 graphics card you're getting the
latest 10th gen i7 six core processor
and you're also getting one terabyte of
SSD compared to 512 on the MacBook Pro
now with the MacBook you're obviously
getting a much better design it's
thinner it's not as large it's not as
heavy much better trackpad pretty good
keyboard as well but the omen is
definitely the king of performance in
this comparison so which one do you buy
well if you're a gay
you're obviously not gonna go with the
MacBook Pro definitely go with the HP
because you're getting so much
performance for only $1,300 and even
though the trackpad isn't great the
display is definitely not good it
actually does not matter to a gamer
because they're gonna be using a mouse
instead of the trackpad and they're
gonna want that 144 Hertz refresh rate
display even though it doesn't look that
great and for anybody doing serious
productivity work you're definitely
going to want to get the MacBook Pro
instead so hopefully you guys enjoy this
video and if you did go ahead and tap
the like button and click the circle
above to subscribe and we're going to
have links to each of these machines
down in the description below thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]